span of six seasons Kings Lenny has had
four rollers seated on the throne of
power Robert Baratheon Joffrey and
Tommen Lannister Baratheon annoucer
slain stir most offense seem to support
Jon's claim to his father Rhaegar
Targaryen as a show made plain in the
season 7 finale Jon Snow is not only
Reger's bastard son but the true and
legitimate heir to the Iron Throne
the Targaryen rule Westeros for hundreds
of years and Prince Rhaegar was legally
Wed to Lyanna Stark making the best Jon
Snow an actual Prince Aegon Targaryen if
you followed the hereditary monarchy Jon
Snow justice brennan's stark stated is
the rightful heir to the Iron Throne
however that's not all he wants to take
on but frankly he did not want to be
king in the north as well but he
accepted it for the sake of his people
or crown me your king I never wanted it
I never asked for it but I accepted it
because the north is my home it's part
of me and I will never stop fighting for
it no ma at the odds so he might as well
accept the role of the king of all
Westeros for the sake of all his people
as well Sam used to believe that little
finger would outwit them all and take
the throne for himself and now that he's
dead some are speculating that verse has
important role yet to play Utterson the
other hand like to argue that Dany is
the true heir to the throne and deserves
rule over the Seven Kingdoms Danny made
reclaiming the Iron Throne her mission
at the end of season 1 her entire
journey since then has been about one
thing making it happen whether she'll
seal the deal is another story entirely
some of the best players in the game of
Thrones Tyrion and Varys believed that
with the right counsel she'd make a
great ruler
last season we've learned that the
prophecy about the prince that was
promised does not necessarily stand for
a meal only as the more proper
translation of the prophecies the prince
or princess that was promised it looks
as if the show is setting her up for
success but that may not be good for
Dany fans have learned her lesson about
predictability more than once with the
series leading us to consider a
possibility of Dany dying in a
childbirth - just like her mother did or
even dying during the Great War against
Knight King but what if every character
that fancy fate ruling Westeros start to
die before the end of Game of Thrones in
that case fans believe that the night
King would reign and end up on the Iron
Throne with the night king destroy a
huge portion of the wall and marching
south with a huge army in the dragon
more and more fanciful thing that in the
end he might sit on the throne
even though the night king will be a
huge danger for rest rows and even
though the living Savile suffered
tremendous loss it's been pretty much
confirmed by george RR martin that he
will be defeated eventually but at what
cost
i've said before that the tone of the
ending that i'm going for his
bittersweet it ends with victory but
it's a bittersweet victory george arm
arm stated according to Daily Telegraph
in 2015 George said something along
lines
killing the night King won't be the end
of Game of Thrones and instead the final
battle will be with Cersei he said in
one interview there is the strong hint
revealed by no less than George our
Martin what this means is even if jon
snow dies fighting the night king and
Danny dies in childbirth the living side
would indeed lose great leaders but the
war would not be lost just yet it's more
likely that Tyrion will take the
leadership of the link side with Jaime
commanding and leading the armies
against the army of the Dead well nice
and he would take care of John and any
child while the war still ravaging long
story short if John and Danny are to die
in let's say episode 5 of season 8 the
final episode would see the living side
and Rotarians leadership against the
night king all Cersei would still be on
the throne basically the night king will
be defeated Cersei will sit on the Iron
Throne while Jon could die fighting the
night king and then he could potentially
die in a childbirth
there's even in the game of Thrones book
clue hinting that nearer Dany nor Jon
will end up ruling Westeros unlike the
television show which is able to
maintain animation viewpoint across a
sprawling ensemble cast George RR
Martin's the Song of Ice and Fire novels
are told from a strict third-person
perspective with each chapter told from
specific characters singular point of
view that means the books can never
feature scenes between non point-of-view
characters what does this have to do
with our question who will win the Game
of Thrones
well once you've read all five of
Martin's now most becomes apparent that
the author never writes from the point
of view of a monarch King Robert was
never a point of view character
none of the would be rulers involved in
the War of the five kings were
point-of-view characters neither
king-beyond-the-wall mance rayder nor
young King Tommen were ever
point-of-view characters rarer robb
story was stole from the perspective of
his mother Catelyn Stannis from Davos
menses through John Thomas stirred
Cersei etc so unless George suddenly
decides to change the fundamental way he
has approached his story for finals
thousands of pages sent 22 years nobody
who has been a point of your character
will end up on the Iron Throne and yes
sir she does have a point of view
chapters in the books but she's not
sitting on the Iron Throne as she does
in the show Asher and her son George are
Arn highlighted multiple times row
towards the end of this amazing journey
will be different meaning some
characters that are dead in the show
will and actually already are alive in
the books and some characters they're
ruling in the show to not rule in the
books however they also stated at the
end of this road will be the same
meaning that the ending will be the same
and whoever wins the Game of Thrones in
the show will win in the books as well
in the end it's likely that the Song of
Ice and Fire will land the same way it
began as a story of cripples bastards
and broken things and not the story of
kings and queens so if none of the
stories protagonists are destined to
Westeros additionally main heroes are
likely to die then who will win the game
of Thrones the assume requirement that
be a non point-of-view character
certainly seems to support the theory
that gimchi will be the king claiming
the throne as a sole surviving offspring
of flayed King Robert Baratheon ginjury
as a sole living heir to Robert and
house Baratheon altogether ginjuries a
contender worth of mentioning his young
is fearless and He wills that were
hammered just like his father used
ginji's motivated solely by revenge
against Lannister so killed his father
and not at all by power that could take
him far beyond than he expected he is
what kick-started the entire saga when
Jon Arryn was killed shortly after he
found out the truth about ginjury it
would be quite a twist of the search for
the heir to the Seven Kingdoms would
actually end with him on the Iron Throne
at the end the most possible fear in my
opinion regarding who will win the Game
of Thrones and sit on the Iron Throne is
no one then he said she wanted to break
the wheel more than once sentian agreed
but the great were eventually being one
and with search the earth road with or
without Daniel I've it's quite possible
that will Shivani to break will be
shattered entirely a new world order
might be exactly what Westeros needs to
rebuild itself in my opinion just know
we'll die fighting the night king Danny
will die in childbirth interior will be
named Lord regent and protector of the
realm to rule in John and Danny stead
until their child comes of age Tyrion
will then break up the Kingdom and allow
the various parts way to self-govern
once more fulfilling things wish of
breaking the wheel and in fact ending
the game of Thrones once for all now
that I introduce to be the possible
ending of Game of Thrones let's take a
look on the very last scene of the
series includes George our mornin to get
there we need to mention the same
narrator theory over a year ago
introduced with a story in which the
story of Game of Thrones has already
been written down and this whole time
being narrated by Cemetery
and the previous season might have
confirmed it before I show you a strong
hint from season 7 episode 2 it is going
favor to this theory let me firstly
briefly introduce with the whole thing
about Sam being the narrator of Game of
Thrones basically I came up to this
while reading John Bradley's interviews
an actor to portray similarly in the
series
long story short Bradley came up with a
theory based on the object in the game
of Thrones opening credits that is
identical to Diaz he said gyroscope is
hanging inside the Citadel John Bradley
theorized and might have even figured
out the game of transcending Breton said
I think it could mean any number of
things one theory is that what we're
seeing now and how we're experiencing
Game of Thrones is Sam telling the story
of Game of Thrones if you take the logic
of the story now the story of Esther ups
and the story of the battle for the Iron
Throne it would be a book in that
library the visual motif of that is
you're about to be told a story the
sense of an idea being told story in
people gaining the knowledge the way Sam
is absorbing the knowledge in library
the Estoril a band the changing map of
Westeros that we see before every single
episode in his theory will represent the
unfolding of a story being told by Sam
himself season six providers wanna probe
is going favor to this theory when
summer arrives at the Citadel he is
greeted by maester who uses the
distinctive pair of glasses to read the
text in front of him those glasses to be
exact its lenses we hear most rarely
seen in each episode of Game of Thrones
in the opening credits as we can see in
every title sequence while zooming in on
the city of King's Landing and while
swimming out of the wall the map is
actually seen through lenses that
appears to be just like those glasses
now let's see how this theory might have
been confirmed or at least hinted in
season 7 Valar Schmitz represents every
gathering books in the Citadel library
archmaester set a line that seems to be
a strong hint for sensually being the
narrator of Game of Thrones mr. fule was
quite the opposite of brilliant stylists
who invented after stories he tells I
wanted to ask you're going to write
history's Tarly you have to do the
research if you want be able to read
your histories you need a bit of style
I'm not writing a chronicle of the wars
following the death of King Robert the
first so he can sit on the shelf
I'll read but you don't like the title
what would you call it there possibly
something a bit more poetic epic fantasy
novels the Song of Ice and Fire which
was later that did in the DHB of
series of Game of Thrones Mon certainly
does sound more poetic this marks the
biggest game Dead Game of Thrones series
my 10 we told Sam looking up from a book
as he finally reads the whole story this
would mean that all events that we've
seen and all events that we're about to
see him already taking place and were
actually written in Sam's book that he
is reading to someone don't you think
that george RR martin would fit
perfectly as the old sam who is looking
up from a book as he finally reads the
whole story to either little Sam or John
child or even to both of them
additionally during one interview George
noted that if he were in the story he'd
probably be similarly he's a great
character Martin said Tyrion might be
who I want to be but Sam is probably
closer to who I actually am the fat kid
who likes to read books and doesn't like
to go up a lot of stairs
altogether this jumper listeria the
support with a few proof deference and
is interesting and what better way to
end game of thrones than with george RR
martin